on rappelle que tu es là pour ton
association merci d'être venu nous voir
vraiment et on va essayer d'aider au
mieux l'association de blaise alors je
vous dis chacun va paix qu'est ce qui
vous connaissez vous le peuple essayé
giroux olivier rivet la peña les appels
au titre olivier girault si vous l'avez
ses 100 euros à l'essai mais forcément
football alors forcément football
mesdames c'est qui djibril cissé
ah oui pas mal malvaux rocco et rocco
siffredi n'est pas il est pas
footballeur olivier giroud donc les voir
benjamin castaldi et son portable très
peu de chose qui réponde brave ou quoi
voilà merci
bon ben alors non c'est pas nous ont dit
en fait l'animal et cinq ans djibril
cissé va répondre à répondre à beinheim
il va dire peut-être elle veut me pécho
un truc comme ça
quoique norsys 17 va pas répondre excuse
moi tu mettras ça après bah oui si ces
droits d'émission ok troisième sonnerie
tu as à blaise
ça va bouger ses doigts que l'équipe est
bonne
reste à l'eau et ça nous a plu qui m'ont
barocco donc aussi fini ça va décrocher
tu vas hésite préparez vos numéros frère
s'est hissée frères voisine ans et une
batte de dire non il est peut-être en
train de bosser sorcier baïda budapest
ça sera bon il va répondre
szirokko réponse et s'emballe alors j'ai
peur du répondeur mais comment tu as on
décroche pas bête à bath en tout cas
vous êtes vraiment respectée celle de
sailly mais il est au ghana ben alors
ça va vite vas-y appel direct ça y est
en métal tu as préparé numéro et que
derrag à la halle et kelly marchés à
thème hatem ben arfa va dire qu'elle a
été menée il ya encore au foot bassar l
on sait pas de qui vient de sortir
c'est pas possible hatem ben arfa les
voit kelly b novelli de dire la nasa
c'est vrai avec un sens j'ai appelé
personne à temps j'ai raté ma croûte
alors n'ont toujours pas vraiment à
coeur joie
gelabert à bibracte plus asie bazil va
eelv a répondu j'espère les mecs vous
rendez compte que y'a personne car
épouse inquiète cas moi ça va répondre
abidjan 5 euros chez avec ma bleus là tu
dis on a en direct sur tp mp avec cyril
hanouna
comment tu vas totti briques bah ça va
très bien on est ouest ça va on est là
pour l'association de blaise matuidi
beau valu ces bourses et s'emballe je
combats a gagné à l'euro à placer sa
peau merci papy mandat on a dit que si
ça marche surtout n'embrasse mais en
direct avec 6 la mena et avec blaise
matuidi
ça va bien un groupe qu'on a gagné son
balcon grâce à toi grâce à toi on a
gagné 100 euros pour l'association de
blaise matuidi il fallait appeler un
sportif donc été appelés pour porto qui
se
[Applaudissements]
rappelez vous un petit bisou qui
candeloro
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
apple s'est parlé on peut désormais des
sommets plus carton rouge enfin voulu un
tchador carton en main carteron louis
bapes et et vous voulez la paix qu est
le doute fait application d'autres non
mais attendez attendez attendez pas à
voir des complots mois moi je vais
essayer d'abord mathieu vous a plu
nelson monfort j'appelle une norme star
c'est bon alors appel énorme star il me
doit beaucoup en plus je pense qu'il va
répondre c'est qu'ils fassent ça vous
allez voir c'est une surprise parce que
jamais dit ça tu expliques tu vas
pleurer êtes non m'énerver dit qui s'est
dit d'horaires regardes tu verras
respectez-moi respecte le sur trois gars
il va paraître monde s'est tu vas pas
répondre il doit tout alors si tu avais
dit qui sait pas ce que je peux rajouter
c'est alors tu peux aller sur 1000 tu
peux aller sur 1000 c'est un poteau à
l'eau ouais mon frère ces matous
[Applaudissements]
comment tu vas
la suite lui
j'ai hâte et marion bartoli mais non
voyons là ou là dedans selon lui dont
l'envoi ce week-end qui vous avez vous
savez qu'il est là quand elle vous l'a
même je lis un message à personne je
paye direct moi même mais non mais non
mais non mais non mais que d'autres ça
tu peux pas appeler teddy riner teddy
riner mais je ne l'appelais répond pas
fallet lago et cet aprem et sa peau si
les conduire à la mêlée chéri moi je
propose est ce que tu veux que j'appelle
au jeu je vais essayer d'appeler antoine
griezmann blesse chez cet art clokey
euros pour page alors là on a mis dos et
blaise est ce que tu veux pas tu me dis
tu me dis est ce que tu veux pas qu'on
essaie d'appeler cristiano ronaldo
oui juste bonjour c'est blaise et c'est
tout on t'aime voilà c'est tout comme si
on dort 6 à dien on le fait pas je vais
essayer d'appeler de gaiman déjà mais
cristiano ronaldo les mecs là c'est mal
numérotée numéro alors et blagny on joue
avec lui avec la grève mais fait tourner
féraud
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle s'appelle antoine j'appelle open
aux manettes on m'a envoyé un message
peut pas décrocher la tête de cuba
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tenir l'un des rôles ou 000 alors je
vous dis moi j'ai choisi numéro en plus
de personnes ne connaît mon numéro donc
j'ai essayé d'appeler antoine gevers
essayé d'appeler antoine voilà on a une
belle manne la très bonne équipe en fait
on attend des cantonales oui c'est un
amour c'est bien c'est un peu court en
ce moment un peu plus long comme ça
c'est pas moi ça que j'aime beaucoup et
beaubien pin ans ça sonne à iba way
société bout amer c'est vrai ouais ça va
ça va ils vous ressemblent un peu
on a du talent alors bye est pas
disponible donc voilà pour l'instant on
est à 1100 euros serait sa dernière je
peux essayer mais ben ça sera pas
cristiano mais je peux c'est vrai que tu
essaies pays et qui va zy 50 humilié
mamadou sakho va bien a dit ben haddou
et je pense qu'il en scooter la zeebo
blaise et et vous voulez essayer mais il
y aura pas mal basiji ça pas mal et c it
what what orateurs des routeurs fini on
finit de saint andré s'est pas candeloro
non
[Rires]
[Musique]
sur le plateau de thé pmp là avec céline
ses impôts directs là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment j'ai mon mot de gaza à tanger
s'est passé tellement de temps en temps
[Rires]
c'est bien d'avoir à courir
[ __ ] mamadou en double et embrasser
mon frère
reda et ses comptes m voilà on vous
lâche le dire et on avec blaise qui est
exceptionnel on voulait de faire un
énorme bisou antenne formule 1 0 je
t'embrasse fort
pragmatiques les tremplins
reda tu dis ça a été créé il ya trois
ans et on va donner pour l'association
de blaise je vous le dis avec l'équipe
de production on va donner 5000 euros
[Applaudissements]